Oh
women should be paid twice as much as
men shut up with hard to wait loser I am
drinking your liberal tears stop are you
sick and tired of trolls ruining your
social media experience yes well then
the troll cliche wiki is for you when a
troll attacks with an insult you've
heard a thousand times before triggered
much delete your account bitch don't
waste your time arguing with them just
head on over to troll cliches dot-com
find the cliche that your troll has been
engaging in copy and paste that hot URL
men send them the link what it's that
easy it's that easy
shut the up snowflake but what if
the troll keeps responding well I wish I
thought of that possibility I did
now you just send them a second URL one
that says you've already lost this
argument just keep sending the link
again and again and again again no and
again I'm not triggered and
again oh dear gender gives you a low IQ
and again maybe stuff yeah yeah yeah
and eventually ah they'll go away for
good
very cool very cool indeed
troll cliches calm try it today